Scot zou lack is in the building
longtime Patriot quarterback who is now
a dynamite radio analyst for the team
right I mean his own specialist calls
are just remarkable easy you know he
really gets in it when he loves the
Patriots and he protects he protects the
Patriots shield he does so I'm just
gonna back just a back track for this
studio audience here and for those in
the Rich Eisen show who may not know
years ago Brady
it was the deflategate hoo-ha sure I was
how many times did I come on the show
and say that the deflategate stuff is
totally off all the time totally up Tom
Brady TV 12 he's missed a Michigan okay
my kids love him I love him everybody
loved the whole household loves him so
after the deflategate before if you
recall he didn't take the four-game
suspension till the year after
so all that craziness went down in the
summer and he he started the season at
home because they won the Super Bowl
right meant nothing but not 2015 correct
so he played the game on NBC and I
tweeted out if he does not do the
postgame interview then you'll know he's
pissed at the NFL cuz he always did it
you know he always says hi mom I mean
he's he's Tom Brady so sure enough he
runs off the field he doesn't do the
postgame interview I'm like oh he must
be pissed there goes Brady running off
the field and I get a call from my
brother-in-law Scott Schuster who is
there in New England listening to people
on the radio named what's cazzo lack
you're getting blown up rich I'm like
who's blowing me up Scott saw likes
blowing me up because they thought I was
criticizing Brady for running off the
field and then this drop it drop it
right there you know what go run another
40 in your suit go run another 40 in
your suit which brother come on out here
Scott so like everybody Ronald applause
everyone
for the job right scrape how great to
see you please look down like these
Michigan men huh there is can you can
you give me an updated version of Goran
and left we pull the microphone I'll
pull it up right there in front of you
play that all the time
hello why were you so pissed at me Scott
you know what it wasn't it wasn't a rich
you weren't near not pissing rich right
rich eyes here piss at the league for
what I don't represent the Lou I know
but when you work for that foul Network
you're the face of the network man okay
Don I appreciate all the guy who runs
40s and they film it and a superimposed
each year to year to year and after only
so many criticisms of Brady can you take
when you know the guy all right but I
you know and again I don't I don't
suppose that you hear every word that I
drop but it you know I thought that that
was an indication in by the way I think
I think I have well-founded indication
that he was pissed it at the NFL he was
that stuff anymore
yeah people that I talked to close to
Tom and from what Tom puts into it I
played with a lot of bad guys in the
league back in the 90s and early 2000s
and to see what this guy does just you
know everything that he stands for his
approach to the game is preparation he
puts everything into it takes care of
his body and for a violation of this and
the magnitude of sort of a PD type
suspension to where you know Edelman
gets caught for something you're gonna
serve two four games Rodney Harrison get
some you're gonna serve the four games
whether or not he did it I mean he's
played better since the violation
supposedly occurred right I mean I'm
getting ready to call my fourth fourth
straight Super Bowl well the thing
that's really most amazing orchestrate
cuz the only reason why we're bringing
up the flake gate is because again I
that's one of our favorite drops on the
rich eyes and shook we hear oh just one
more time we're one more time you know
what go run another 40 in your suit okay
that's which by the way they probably
smoked my forehead they like a four to
five which by the way Scott like great
Michigan men we don't hear the noise we
we just keep showing up again you know
what it was eyes kept running the 40
just like Tom keeps showing up at the
Super Bowl you know look at this some of
you guys I don't look at all those
Patriots coverage
nice things take this helmet if you wish
if you wish
no but the flake gate is so yesterday's
news to me that I think is really
remarkable and I'd love for you to get
put some meat on the bones if there
still is anything was last year at this
time we were talking about Jimmy G and
did Tom demand that he get out and you
know his trainer being told you got to
work from across the street and him and
Belichick weren't doing well and then
Tom pleads the fifth to to Jim Gray and
yet it doesn't matter here we are is
hashtag we're still here again right I
mean is there any lingering there's all
I've been around these both these guys
for a long time
it's tough it's tough for me to answer
what transpired last year because
obviously there's some sort of drama or
else we wouldn't have been in the
position we were in right books are
being written whether it's documented
and the crazy thing is nothing comes out
of New England but for a guy to have a
book out and put an article out to say
that he's talked to dozens of people
from with any organization that's that's
that's a stretch for me but you know
Bill's very demanding he's tough to play
for I think Tom reiterates that but I
didn't even ever heard Tom last year
everyone say I love him I love him as a
coach I love playing for him something
got buried from the end of February when
he sat there at the end of Tom versus
time and said you know I'm sitting there
to treat my Achilles they treat my hand
he had a big gash on his hand you know
after that Jacksonville game and you
gotta answer your convictions you answer
you ask her so why do I play this game
why do I put myself through this and
until you can answer that you got to
find something else to do if you're not
happy so in February he threw for 505
yards against Philly and a loss should
have won that Super Bowl that strip sack
didn't happened we were going down to
scores no doubt about it but he was not
happy at the end of February and he he
stayed away from the team which is very
unlike Tom Brady it's it's not a Brady
thing to do is the only quarterback in
the league to not participate in the
offseason program right that doesn't
happen I don't care who's your coach and
he came back for whatever reason whether
it was between ownership and mr. crafts
great you know the brand is great but he
said at the end of last year everybody
needs to check their egos and I think
Bill did it I think Tom did it and I
think Robert did it and I think for the
betterment of the team Alyce Guerrero's
back in there he's on our plane Brady's
happy as a clam with winning football
games we're able to
the football we have to throw it we
could throw it the tight-end looks like
he's starting to come around Edelman's
healthy and it just seems like this is
the best team we had going into Super
Bowl out of the five Super Bowls what
I'm gonna call are you serious yeah I
just I think it from a health standpoint
I'd and I say that because none of our
lime and knock on wood this is wood yes
right some for me it might be coated
with some I have Scott right yeah I mean
our offensive line stayed together the
entire year and have that continuity a
they've been incredible I mean the you
know obviously Michelle and and fans
here from Atlanta know all about Sony
Michelle because it's way you know sorry
Kuwait so obviously he's been tremendous
but it's also white and Rex Burkhead and
yet I mean it and and that's what I was
saying that if Brady can hand it off to
somebody who is that productive and also
score enough points to win by getting
the ball out of his hands and two to two
and a half seconds and not have to throw
beyond ten yards
eighty percent of the time to be
successful he will play till he's 60
I think the league's different right the
league's different and other other
people against Brady the people that
cliff people who I get very irritated
with they work at another network but
what a people there's four letters left
people okay Brady's hit the cliff you
know II the the the downward spiral has
begun he's gotten better since the play
game for whatever reason you look at the
way the ball comes out of his hand his
ability to grip the ball the ball
handling in Kansas City last week where
it's literally 10 degrees with about a
three three degree wind chill out there
you can't hear anything everything is
silent count the running game silent
count passing game we didn't up one
penalty so his ability to operate you
look at the checks the hand signals the
attention to detail from the mental
aspect of the game is the most
impressive thing beyond the physical
part of it when that all comes together
like we've seen it come together that
was a big win against the Chargers at
home you put thirty five on the board to
start that game you going with a big
lead at half time you could play do you
play a different type of defense when
you do that but I have a lead you can
gamble a little bit more you could blitz
but these throws in this Kansas City
game underdress bad conditions you know
see the way they block up the pocket
can't cover Edelman in the middle of the
field elements healthiest as healthy as
he's ever been and and he looks good I
know he had those four weeks off
yeah Scott Soller here on the Rich Eisen
show Patriots radio analyst former
Patriot here on the Rich Eisen show now
you mentioned the cliff people right at
the ESPN people I mean you gotta like
that though cuz what else you gonna
complain about how else you gonna say
that you're not how else you gonna say
you're an underdog Scott with with ten
Super Bowl appearances in the last
quarter century and good and nine under
Brady and Belichick how else did how
else you gonna pound on the table and
say poor us people don't think we're
we're good when by the way I said the
Patriots were winning the AFC I mean
seriously
do they really when did I say Oh week
Labor Day labor dicey laid all these
people take a victory lap so I picked
the Rams I picked the Patriots I will
say Scott he actually did I did no no
because I understand what division in
which the Patriots play I understand
that when you come to the the game
against New England you are taking on
the team that is the best yeah at
boiling it down to better be Who am I
playing against today it snapped to snap
quarter-to-quarter moment-to-moment
it's unbelievable how Belichick and
Brady do that but do they really
seriously deep down deep down believe
that people think that the Patriots
can't win yes football yeah they really
they're not this football game but I
don't think they they know they're
confident going it I think obviously
they're the favorite they're gonna win
this game but I just I can't believe
that there's a really believe takes what
everybody believes an underdog takes one
guy criticized I've been part of the
blood I'll check tree as to where your
inside and it's one little thing it
could be you know this guy slow now you
got the corner row be the kid did uh
what's his life yeah Nicko Robbie Coman
Roby Coleman who's who should have been
called for that penalty against the
Saints should I play in the Saints right
now by the way right but um sorry so you
get the hit you get that that hit that
wasn't called so he's already he's from
Buffalo former buffalo nickel guy he's
already saying yeah we started to see
the stuff in Buffalo but Brady's old you
could tell just some of the balls don't
come out right yeah well he don't say
anything smart he's
do listen cuz you know bills gonna run
it off he's gonna have it in Toms Locker
this guy said that he will do that right
oh yeah they say they ignore the noise
they they absorb all the noise is what
they do they internalize it then they
try to figure out which is gonna move
which which clip which guy's gonna say
the one thing that's gonna piss off the
most that's the thing we're gonna run
with it's like Brady says we're still
here cuz nobody said you'd still be here
Scott so like here in the Rich Eisen
show we showed it on our show the other
day Brockman who's our resident Masshole
over there
mic drop he tweeted it out the other day
too and I saw the film sessions you do
with Bill Oh gala check par amazing no
and it's it shows a side to him that he
rarely shows yeah I mean what are you
what is from your position Scott you see
and you see him working at - by the way
he's terrific at the telestrator - I
mean what is what do you see when you do
those the exciting thing is he I talked
to Bill early in two weeks we filmed
that show usually on a Tuesday or
Wednesday prepare for the next week and
he picks five or six plays for the next
opponent and what we'll do is we'll do a
wrap-up segment if we win the football
game he'll pick 17 like he got all
excited after San Diego we had 17 place
so were plays of the week
so he'll tee up something we talked
about earlier in a week here's the
formation I showed you last Tuesday they
stacked the two receivers they bring
them in we knew that those two safeties
were gonna split this way we get Julian
up in the middle like this is the Kansas
City part of it three straight third and
tens they hit - City they knew that if
they throw a certain formation out there
like he's diagram in here as you could
see we knew that Kansas City's going to
cover too deep man-to-man underneath
which means elements gonna be brought
down at Short motion he's gonna go to
the middle throws the hand up he sees it
and this is where he and Tom are on that
sort of level that's not the intended
route but Julian knows cover - man I'm
going right in the middle throw the hand
up and Brady sticks on this is third and
tenth it shouldn't happen I know it's
not happening it's Lee I know so what do
you think this week makes a you know
what do you think McVeigh presents as a
challenge
he's got a misdirection in the speed I
think he does a fantastic job with Goff
he does a nice job sort of walking him
through it up until 15 seconds left on
that play clock to where he could stop
talking to the quarterback right so it
really sets it up like hey take a peek
backside maybe
we got cover 6 or covered - hey we got
him in man here so I think the motion
and we know Brandon cooks we have Rena
cooks he was a real productive player we
loved them obviously got hurt that first
driving Super Bowl which killed us last
year we still had a productive Super
Bowl but just the constant formation
motion play fake and it's all
misdirection and that's the thing you
got to you got to be sound with your
keys you got you understand what you
mean defensively and you can't overload
them I mean they could sit there you can
have 20 meetings and walkthroughs the
problem is if you give them too much
information as I player you overthink
things at some point you got to minimize
it let's figure out okay let's see what
they do let's take a peek at it for
three series this is where Bill Josh it
was Matt Patricia a year ago yep and now
Brian Flores who's a fantastic young
defense of mine he's gonna be the next
Miami head coach they adjust serious -
serious - series cuz you could sit there
- Rams could sit there try game plan for
New England we ran a ball for 279 yards
against Buffalo in week 16 then he threw
it all over for the Jets and then at San
Diego where we mix and match it with
Burkett in there and then you don't see
James White then you see James White
against Kansas City you're an organism
they're not the same week the week and
everyone is I know that I know that but
McVeigh's got to know that - and
Belichick so it's funny how you say that
you just have to boil it down
thus do your job I mean it just say it
in three words that's it basically like
tell them yeah this is what you need to
do don't take that cheese when they move
around here don't smoke and mirrors just
go ahead and do your job if we tell you
which is why if I'm not mistaken
being around Willie McGinest as much as
I happen is good which is why the first
four to six weeks sometimes four
Patriots season the defense doesn't look
as good because there's too many guys
out there may be new to the team who
just freelance and they it takes them a
while to understand no no no no no that
doesn't happen here in New England yes
doing your job we know where you should
be you should now understand where you
should be and then we're all wind up in
the Super Bowl together yeah and that's
a great point
and I think the experience of the game -
and I remember calling a game where we
were down twenty eight to three with a
quarter left against against Atlanta a
couple of years ago careful careful now
and a no but they talked about Brady
Brady at the door neck' said we knew we
knew we had him where he won
and I'm throwing things up in the booth
and I'm like I'm going over ticket
prices flew my wife down my sister at
for postgame party passes you know Snoop
was gonna play it and I'm like I don't
even want to go and my play-by-play guy
saying it's okay if they come out score
first which he didn't they won came out
second half right what three now when
they were down 18 they go down at score
we're down we're down 25 I'm like it's
ball game it's over and Brady said we
knew we had him because they started to
tire up front
nobody else says it like mcvane golf
aren't gonna say that on Sunday because
they didn't have that experience Tom
said we knew at halftime it's an
extended halftime so they had talked
just for 10 minutes 25 minutes as
opposed to 12 you're gonna come out and
we just we could tell that they were
starting to get gas in the back end and
he started to muddy the middle of that
field so we said we're going outside
we're going to Hogan we're going to
Mitchell and we didn't have Gronk we had
element who made that fantastic catch
I'm a deflection but it's really
Martellus Bennett was your tight net
that's right and we said we're gonna
throw it every single play they put
James White in the backfield I'll set it
Elena couldn't stop it and then once
that offense gets going it starts it's
like Matt Slater and over time the other
day we want the ball like they want to
open a coin toss they're gonna take the
balls on that Scott so like here in the
Rich Eisen show before I let you go how
do you come up with the phrases that you
use show ponies and unicorns it's not
it's organic man I'm so in it I don't
plan anything it's crazy like a mirror I
said it last week America's worst
nightmares back sorry Atlanta yeah like
you don't want to see us here but we're
here we're back so that was it America's
worst night show i mean i was thinking
bread yeah you know people are leaving
the building who left the building
mmm you know show ponies something it's
fancy so it's running around a unicorn
mythical creature you never see that's
Brady I don't know where to where I'm a
big early eighties Wendy's I see the two
old lady sliding back and forth in that
seat there screaming where's the beef
and it just all came out my producer sat
me down after that he said you know
don't ever do that again it's a horse
call you'll ever have a thing with
virals the number one call the year
everybody steals play it so I don't
wanna I don't want to undercut your
producer but that's I would not take
that advice now yesterday last thing for
you Scott yes don't like Brady drops the
mic he threw the mic he threw up and
then you dropped it
I have my hand in my pocket you can show
the video so I gotta it's called sten
degrees we have 40,000 people for it's
amazing it's amazing but but you weren't
expecting the the microphone it's my way
lips it's my hands in my pocket I'm
trying to emcee the rest I'm seeing a
program your profession you're starting
to look at the audience this way yeah
Brady hits me it hits here I almost end
up double catch in it so it was almost a
hell of a catch rich so we get on the
buses about tipping my phones lighting
up at a time and he's on bus three I'm
on bus six and he goes hey man just want
to say sorry goes by the way it's my
first incompletion of the week it'll be
my life well that's a mic drop moment
right there hey Scott thanks for coming
on
I appreciate you saying that because
again putting a drop to your we've come
here one last time come here just one
more time here cuz I'm just one so go
run another forty in your suit okay I'm
gonna do it nobody black suits yeah
black suit black tie right down the
middle I just have one I'm not gonna
wear a black suit this time it's just a
show logo here that's all yeah I don't
know what I'm gonna wear yet all I know
is I'm just I just gonna try and run I'm
gonna try and run like the wind so you
run for the cops that's like it's a good
money guy from New York just got out of
Wall Street yeah feds are chasing it's a
very Don Draper look that's for sure
good to see you Scott have a great time
calling the game Scott so like here on
the riches show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience